think that a family going for a walk
couldn't make it home
to think that that casual
walk around the block in our
neighborhood would be
one's last to think that you can't
walk safely down your own street
and to think about what that means for a
muslim family
right now people are talking to their
families and saying you know what maybe
you shouldn't go for a walk
there are people literally thinking
about whether they should walk out their
front door
in our country we think about what that
means
some people have said this is not our
canada
and i think about what that means when
people say this is not our canada
this happened in london ontario i lived
in london ontario for five years
i loved my time there i think about the
fact that my parents chose to be canada
are home i love my home i love this
place
but the reality is this is our canada
this
is our canada our canada
is a place where 215 little kids were
found dead
in unmarked graves are canada's a place
where you can't walk down the streets
if you were a hijab because you will be
killed this is our canada
we can't deny it we can't reject that
because it does no one any
help the reality is our canada is a
place
of racism of violence of genocide of
indigenous people
and our county is a place where muslims
aren't safe they aren't
they aren't safe muslims are not safe in
this country
and muslims wonder i've spoken to people
they wonder how many more lives will it
take
how many more families will be mauled
mild
down the street how many more families
will be killed
before we do something
innocent people were killed while
praying
in a place of prayer in a masjid in a
mosque in quebec
gunned down a man was was a muslim man
in toronto was knifed and killed
and both of those incidents we know very
clearly that it was directly because of
hate
it was because of hate there was so much
hate
towards someone that they did not know
just because of who they were
because of how they prayed because of
what they look like
that is a reality people live with that
every day
they walk the streets wondering if i
will be attacked
just because the way i look not because
of it of an enemy that i have
not because of someone who's got a
problem with me will i be attacked
today just because the way i look that
is a real question people ask
wow what what a life to live that you've
gotta wonder about that
and we think about people that left
violence
they fled persecution refugees
they come to this country thinking i'm
gonna be safe here
this is a place of safety and they're
not safe
so this is what we're going to be
talking about and discussing with my
next guest who's an activist
community leader educator on comparative
religion
our brother waseem razvi how are you
brother assalamu alaikum
for having me with you on the show
alhamdulillah
did i leave anything out when i
introduced you that you'd like to add
no that was already too big i guess
alhamdulillah
so what is your reaction when you saw
this is now just to make it
clear this is not a muslim many people
they equate someone with a turban like
this or the rapping that the sikhs have
specifically
their tradition and they think that's a
muslim so this is not even a muslim
who's speaking uh
on behalf of this terrorist attack that
happened
what's your reaction to what some of the
things that he was talking about
see i think this was just me saying in
canadian parliament and i think he's
he's
uh he's a fair voice who's raising uh
the voice against the hatred that is
happening
uh right now as we speak in canada um it
is a fair voice that we need to
appreciate
um along with the voice of the prime
minister of canada uh justin trudeau
um and there are fair voices that are
out there um
which are speaking um the language that
must be spoken
uh in times of uh descent in times of uh
depression
in times of anxiety that that people are
going through
so i believe it is it is a fair voice
but there is a lot of work and action to
be done
along with the words
so what do you think we can we can learn
from this you know what do you think uh
from what we're seeing now what are the
things that we want to
go ahead and talk about that you think
are very the most important points that
we should cover
right i think see first of all just for
for all the viewers out there you know
i'm sure everybody has come across this
uh
this terrible terrorist attack that has
taken place in canada
on sixth of june sunday um just earlier
uh
by the end of last week uh but it's just
good to give a quick brief to the people
what's happening what has happened
what we're talking about right now is is
a terrible
terrorist attack a horrendous one that
has shaken
the entire canadian society as well the
entire world is watching
in shock and agony as to what has
happened
how could somebody be so barbaric so
hate filled
uh so islamophobic that they need to go
out in a truck and
spot a family and drive
over them mow them under the the tires
of your truck
how how barbaric would you be to do
that exactly just imagine three
generations
of a family three generations the
grandparent
the parents the father and the mother
and the sister the sibling
of of the of the injured child a
nine-year-old child
five members of a family were mowed down
under a truck
by a terrorist in
in canada in broad daylight on a quiet
sunday
okay are we not talking about somewhere
in iraq or in afghanistan
as as the the media tries to portray
from time to time
we're not talking about palestine right
now we are talking about
the safe streets of canada this is what
has exactly happened
just a couple of days ago in in um
in canada and this is the city of london
um in canada which we are talking about
the state of ontario
now tonight many of the now what we want
to
go further from there is who is this
terrorist
what are we uh what do we know about him
uh this is something that we may uh you
know explore further into
yeah that's that's very important
because some of the points
that are very important we're seeing one
it's just interesting
uh and it's always when something like
this happens
you know you start to as a muslim you
start to see many of the double
standards
because the majority of time if this
was someone who had the name ahmed or
muhammad
or just some person who was you know
literally just mentally deranged he just
got out of a mental hospital whatever
the case had you know he's not
establishing islam in his life but
because he's somehow
maybe new a muslim or comes from a
muslim family
but is not implementing any of the
tenets of islam
right away his whole life will be put on
display
very true very true i think it is very
important that you have uh
pointed out the double standards of
media and i would extend it to the
politicians the opportunistic
politicians as well um
when we see the name you know it's not
that
the moment the name sounds islamic
sounds muslim
that's it that's where the media starts
its trail
that's where they start their charging
they they start to
do their own judgments um on the face of
it they put out
the face of the of the culprit they put
out the entire family out there
they will put out all the possible
horrible things of this person
you know he had this in his family he
had this in his lifetime
bringing out the most evil possible
aspects of that person and blame
the entire community rather the entirety
of the faith
and they start to question every single
teaching of islam they will
they will you know start to ponder on
every single verse of the quran which
talks about
fighting which talks about dealing with
the politics which talks about
responding or reacting or taking a
revenge they will
bisect every single aspect of islam
but now the moment you see that the
perpetrator doesn't
sound muslim or maybe you can even call
doesn't look like a muslim
you see the the softness of the language
of the media
and the appropriate language of the
politicians a very cautious
very careful language you know although
we appreciate what we just saw
from the canadian politicians uh we
really appreciate that so i'm not really
questioning their their intentions there
however i believe the discourse needs to
change
the language needs to change we cannot
make
generic statements that these are hate
filled attacks
yes it is hateful attack but this
hate-filled attack is
islamophobic in its nature what are the
what are the ideologies behind these
attacks these are not happening in
vacuum
when a muslim does an attack you try
find out which school he went
which college which university his
friends his suburb his locality
his teacher who he used to watch on the
television
on his laptop which islamic speakers he
used to watch
everyone is blamed in that attack in
that criminality
but now when there is a terrorist
who doesn't happen to be muslim and
happens to be from another faith and
will come that come to that
there is no there's no inquisitiveness
there is no query
of his whereabouts there's no query of
his associations
he's like a good guy he has always been
a very nice guy
he's out there we just don't know why he
did that so the police
charges him but shuts the case you know
let me let me just bring out
the case of the new zealand christchurch
terrorist attack yes the prime minister
of new zealand we appreciate her for
standing firm
and rounding up the culprit putting
terror laws against him
and charging him great but just one
person
just one criminal that's all where are
these associates
where are the terror raids on on 50
houses
where are the 500 intelligence bureau
officers who are going to be
raiding the the houses of those people
who radicalize this terrorist
where are the houses being raided of
those people
who who give who did the propaganda to
make him an extremist he can't just
wake up one night and in the morning go
out to do a terror attack
that is not how it works where is the
entire upbringing of this terrorist
which church used to go which priests he
used to listen to
where is the entire interrogation of
this person
and this is my concern as much we
appreciate
the government the prime minister and
and and the
and the leaders of the community who are
taking
the discourse a language to condemn this
yes condemning is a step one
but the matter doesn't end there we need
to see concrete actions
we need to lobby in order to make
changes
to curb these incidents from happening
otherwise
it's a continuous prac it's a regular
practice we will have to wait for
another
similar terrorist attack another day
condemn it go back to work wait for
another terrorist attack
you're seeing that the the majority
reports are not calling it a terrorist
attack you have one here
actually that is saying alleged
christian terrorists who mowed down
muslim family was laughing as he got out
of his
blood covered truck you also you don't
see many pictures
of him floating around you don't see you
don't see um
like this picture here and a few of the
others here's another picture of him
yep so that's interesting and then we
have this uh
this report here that we can go ahead
and get your reaction to
sure um that is i think one of the only
show okay we'll go for the report yeah
okay details around the suspect's life
remain shrouded in mystery i spoke to a
number of his friends who live in this
community who
say they are in shock but also in
disbelief
they say they never had any inkling that
their friend could allegedly be capable
of carrying
out such an atrocity i would never
believe that he could have done
something like this at all anyone else i
would believe could do this but nate not
at all yeah why do you say that it's
just not his personality like at all
like this is quite a shock armand
moridporian has known the suspect
nathaniel veltman for several years and
last saw him just three weeks ago
they worked together in the shipping
department at this egg farm in the
nearby community of strathroy
london police visited the planet tuesday
afternoon murad poryan's family is from
iran
and he was raised to be a muslim but
says the suspect never appeared to take
issue with that like he never ever
thought twice about
like me and him were great friends he
helped me out a lot when i was going
through a lot of rough stuff
no one answered the door at his parents
home friends say he'd had a fight with
his family and moved out a few years ago
his grandmother passed away on friday
morad paurian says the suspect had been
arrested before for public intoxication
but otherwise was a devout christian who
mostly stayed out of trouble
quiet friendly homeschooled christian
kid literally
and that is now a question for police
investigators to answer
how does a so-called quiet friendly
christian
kid become an alleged mass murderer
we have scoured his social media
accounts online and turned up
very little the accounts didn't have
much in the way of content at all
police say he had no criminal record no
known ties to any hate group
and at this point donna they believe he
was working alone
chilton
uh one is that that we don't take this
opportunity to like it's not like you
know a game oh oh
now he's christian now we're going to
link me and use this know
is to point out a the hypocrisy because
it's clearly
you know something that was laid out
that he is he's a christian
and now what's the christian community
and the just the world the world at
large usually
like you were saying have happened the
person
perpetrator is somehow linked to being a
muslim even though he's fixing islam and
going against
the teachings of islam it's exploited
matt mack
so we condemn groups such as daesh
you know saint state you know and all
these other fringe elements but they
pump them up
as if they represent mainstream islam
so where are the communities now the
cloud out
and to do like you were saying to call
these
individuals out who are within uh
some of the extinction communities
they're in there
there right these some of these extreme
implements like i'll give you an example
example
you have and it's not a small group you
have like for instance
in uh former yugoslavia yeah you have
the uh
techniques you know one of the biggest
genocides after
world war ii and this is where the
person who gone down in new zealand
he was actually someone who was a fan
man
and these were those these two
terrorists
so it's listening to something that they
base
their philosophy or the ideology it's
acted
here so what do you think when when
these dubliners are
so blatant are you there yep we lost
your camera
yes
uh no we lost your camera
okay just give me a sec
are you able to see me now no not yet no
there you go you're back you're back
with us yes uh
yeah yes so i think i think very
important aspects that you just uh
pointed out that you know uh
one of the articles that you just uh
showed is from independent
um the newspaper and it refers to the
to the attacker to the terrorists as a
christian terrorist
now we're not saying that this is the
right label
however it is important to show this
without any offense to our christian
friends
because this is exactly what the media
has been doing
with anyone sounding muslims they have
always made sure that they call them
muslim terrorists but now
when it comes to a non-muslim they may
not refer to him as christian terrorist
we don't agree with the label
however if it was about
labeling every terrorist by their faith
then this would have been the right
title to call this terrorist
as christian terrorist let me bring out
his name to you
which is nathaniel wealthman
that's the terrorist that's the truck
driver who mowed down
the three generations of absal family
in this attack four people died and lost
their lives
and the fifth person a child of nine
years old
is battling with serious injuries in the
hospital in canada
now the second video that you showed
interestingly the video portrays the
the interviews with one of his workmates
one of his colleagues
and one of his friends and they
all seem to portray that this was a
peaceful person this was
a nice guy and this was a person
who had no ties to any
terrorist groups or right-wing extremist
groups or any process of radicalization
so in short they're going to soon call
him
a lone wolf meaning
you know look at this picture a very fun
loving
simple person you know doing fishing
right at the corner of the river
at the edges of the river what what are
they trying to portray where i
where is the image of this bloody
terrorist
wearing the army dress
wearing an army helmet that is how he
attacked this family
there were people who pictured him
according to this article in independent
newspaper
it says that nathaniel
who after attacking and killing he went
to a car park
and stopped there behind a taxi asked
the taxi driver
to ring the police and call them because
he has murdered
some people and the taxi driver does say
that he saw blood on the tires and the
front of the
of the car of the truck when the police
came
to take him out of the car he was
laughing
this terrorist was laughing when he was
taken out
as the newspapers have reported this was
a premeditated
well-planned terrorist attack
now i'm not going to be accepting that
this was
a lone wolf who just woke up one fine
morning
and went out to kill somebody this is
not
how it works in the field of terrorism
let me quote you
one of the terror experts professor
robert pape
terrorism expert from university of
chicago
in his study of 25 years of terrorist
attacks
he says that terrorists do attack
and their attacks may be linked to
overseas incidents military
interventions
and geopolitical scenarios
that may impact a person to do a
terrorist attack
now i'm not linking this terrorist
attack directly to one particular
incident but let's just see what has
happened in the last couple of weeks
and last couple of months globally
one of the things that has happened is
the palestine
israel conflict that you may call or the
genocide
that the israel has been inflicting on
the
innocent indigenous palestinians
living in palestine we just saw that
all of this i'm not saying this has got
a direct link to that but my point is as
professor robert pape
points out terrorists do attacks
for reasons that may well be beyond our
borders
the thing is this person is a christian
terrorist
what made him do this attack they're
going to call him a lone wolf
which we should disagree with and we
must raise our concerns
and voice to find out his associates
who radicalized him he must definitely
be watching somebody online he must be
talking to somebody online
he is listening to certain propaganda
commentaries out there
so it begs the question where
is this ideology coming from let me
point out a few things
the white supremacist ideology
the right-wing extremism the nationalism
the religious fanatics these are some
ideologies to be named
which are directly responsible for many
of the terrorist attacks against muslims
what are the reasons for this if you
look at the reasons if you point out the
reasons the reasons are
constant islamophobic language
by the opportunistic politicians by the
tabloid
media outlets by propagandists
such as journalists and media
commentators
they are fueling this hatred instigating
violence
i refuse to call this terrorist
nathaniel
wealthman a lone wolf rather i call him
a foot soldier but the masterminds
and the think tanks behind him are the
real culprits and they need to be
accountable
for being responsible for the
radicalization of this person
we have a few comments on several uh
many comments coming in here's one of
them
how would you respond to this yeah well
we've got stephen here
who says just convert to christianism
then you will not have a problem in
canada
and do not forget where across a visible
cross
so canadians will see you are christian
well
um to stephen i say you know appreciate
his comment here
however just to bring the truth and the
facts to him
is this very person nathaniel wealthman
was a devout christian according to his
close
close circle friends he was a christian
he was a man associated to god
and he was a young 20 year old person
so being christian is not going to defy
him
or anyone from committing a terrorist
attack rather
i got to say rather it might be the very
reason
for him attacking muslims because there
is a lot of
hate spewed within the christian circles
by the apologists by the politicians and
by the christian preachers
all of this does have an impact
on a christian who is listening to all
of this
we got another comment by muhammad
al-mari he says christianity has nothing
to do with individual behaviors
media and political lobbies are the ones
to blame for sure
definitely brother muhammad i appreciate
your comment that is exactly what we are
saying as well
however we are trying to point out
the dual the double standards the
hypocrisy
of media outlets and politicians when
they see a
terrorist who happens to be muslim they
immediately label it as
muslim terrorism but look at
the honesty and sincerity of the muslims
as brother muhammad just pointed out we
don't blame christianity
rather we blame the language of hate we
blame the racism
we blame the politicians and the media's
language
we've got mukit khan who is saying mass
murderer unfortunately sounds
less dangerous than terrorism these days
they are carefully structuring their
words for propaganda
definitely agree with you khan for for
pointing this out
this is exactly what we are trying to
raise right now that
the language needs to really be very
specific
we can't get away by saying this is a
hate-filled attack
this is a racist attack this is an
islamophobic attack
yes it is all of these but it is
important to call it a terrorist
attack committed by an anti-muslim
christian who may be influenced
by the events and attacks taking place
overseas such as the attacks committed
by
the zionists against the palestinians
such as the attacks committed by the
systemic
racism by the by the states
by the governments bombing iraq and
afghanistan for years
and saying that they are the enemies of
christians this is what is
bringing these terrorists and the and
the
violence to the streets of western
countries
um imani says these terrorist racist
people are planted
and to start hate wars between the
community well that could very well
be the case um uh however i would say
that these
are possibly foot soldiers these are
people who are
impacted by the by the anti-immigration
rhetoric
these are the people who are impacted by
the slamming the
constant islamophobic stemming and
through this
these people are provoked instigated
motivated to attack muslims this is how
the hate takes place
this is how discrimination takes place
in the society
this is how people go after innocent
people
and murder them because they think or
they are programmed and brainwashed
to believe that someone's going to
attack them
so uh in concluding again we don't blame
christianity for the action of
some christians who might do some evil
action just like in this case one who
did
in the same way you shouldn't go ahead
and
often repeat try to blame islam for the
action
of some lunatic who does something
totally against islam
so this is very very clear where where
are we moving forward from this
yes uh i think this is this is a very
very um
important for all of us um to to see
where do we go
forward from here as much our hearts are
in pain
as much we are saddened by this
horrendous attack
let us make sure that we know our steps
to stop something similar from happening
you know let me bring it bring to you
this is not the first terrorist attack
against a muslim
on canadian soil let me just mention a
couple
you know one of the biggest terrorist
attacks that took place against muslims
in canada
was in january 2017 in cuba city mosque
which is popular as cubic city mosque
massacre
a gunman gunned down six people
to death and another 19 people were
injured
by firing inside the mosque while people
were praying
this was one of the biggest terrorist
attacks against muslims in canada
followed by another one in in september
2020 in imo mosque where the caretaker
was
murdered brutally with a knife attack
in the car park of the mosque then
earlier this year
just earlier this year in march 2021
black muslim women were
attacked in the middle of the street in
edmonton
in in in alberta and
now we hear about this attack my point
here is
this is a series of attacks this is not
a one attack
this is not a not a lone wolf thing this
is not a one-off incident
there this is in the making for years
and with all that the canadian
government is doing why are they not
able to stop
such terrorist attacks i'll tell you the
reason
the reason is they are going after
individual
criminal the individual terrorist and
they're charging him
great but they are not holding
the people who are responsible
who should be accountable for using the
language
for instigating for provoking these
foot soldiers and i call these people
as masterminds of the terrorist attacks
they are the ones who are spewing hatred
in the discourse in the society in the
language that they speak
the opportunistic politicians and the
media mughals
they are continuously speaking this
language
which creates an environment of hate
leading to violence so islamophobia
is not just something that is about
discrimination
islamophobia is terrorism and
islamophobia
kills so what needs to be done we need
to lobby
we need to raise our voice that the
government the intelligence departments
and the police of the departments they
should go
after those who radicalize these people
those who spew the extremist
ideology out there it is only then
they will be able to stop this terrorism
called islamophobia against muslims
brother waseem thank you so much for
spending some time with us
and discussing this very important issue
brother just one point i would like to
add especially for our muslim
uh viewers you know when such incidents
take place
yes on one hand we become very depressed
and on the other hand we do want to do
something
but wait what is our individual action
what do i do
as an individual how do i comprehend
this whole scenario
when a muslim is murdered or killed we
have the glad tidings from allah
mentioned in the quran
that if a person is killed in this for
the sake of allah on the in the path of
allah
then they are considered as motives as
shuhada
and allah says in the quran do not call
them dead
they are living for you do not know how
the living is
so we pray to allah that this muslim
family
which has faced the brutality the evil
face
of of humanity may allah count them
amongst the
and raise their ranks in general
about those who do these attacks these
terrorists
even if they get away with their crime
in this world
my dear brothers and sisters allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's
judgment his court is not going to spare
them
allah says in the quran in surah surah
number 4
93 and whoever
kills a believer intentionally his
abode is hell fire forever
and allah curses him and the wrath of
allah will be upon him
and allah is preparing a severe
punishment
for such terrorists criminals and
murderers
lastly what do i do as an individual
where do i go from here what do i enu
do in order to contribute to the peace
of the society
allah commands us in the quran to convey
the message of islam
my dear brothers and sisters
islamophobia one of the ways to tackle
it
is to spread the teachings of islam
let me give you the warning that allah
gave in the quran in surah
surah number 5 67 allah advises
and warns the prophet sallallahu islam
and allah says
o messenger can weigh
whatever has been revealed to you if you
do not convey
then you have not fulfilled the
responsibility of conveying the message
if allah is advising the prophet
to make sure that he conveys the message
of islam that is thus dawah of islam
then my dear brothers and sisters i in
you are also
responsible for conveying the message of
islam
to our fellow canadians to our fellow
americans to our fellow australians
to our neighbors to our work colleagues
to our friends
who are not yet muslims it is absolutely
necessary
that we utilize this opportunity and
turn it into
an opportunity for dawah for talking and
teaching about islam
to one and all i think that's brilliant
taking that away for the community
leaders in canada
in america and the uk all over the world
what we've seen is
that some of the most effective ways of
connecting with the communities out
there and dispelling many of the
misconceptions
connecting people with muslims helping
them understand islam
is education open houses open the
masjids
and invite the peoples because
you see a lot of this a lot of these
people who are capitalizing
you know and spreading misinformation
and this poisons the hearts and minds
and people have
all these false images in their head and
false information about islam which can
cause them to
react you know in a way very true at
least
leads to this yeah i think the the
christchurch attack in new zealand after
that there were mosque open days
there were people who came to mosque and
subhanall they've been
reports of hundreds of new zealanders
embracing islam
that is that is something that could be
the consequence that could be the result
that could be what is happening next
after such terrorist attacks
if we muslims could open the doors of
mosques
and in our hearts for our fellow
non-muslim friends
increase the budget of dawa it's also a
shame that you have in masjids
it's like one two percent and
and this is something that is pr it's
public relations so
it's very very important what would you
say to the community leaders the board
members of masjids
you know every masjid should have a
dawah committee and so much funds
allocated to help
educate people share this message what
do you think about that
i think very very important uh brother
eddie for for raising that and i think
uh obviously you know we are all
individuals but i think as much we can
communicate and convey to our leaders to
the mosque boards
that you know they should assign a
specific committee
and budget in order to do dawah in each
and every mosque you know the mosque
a place of sujood is an open door
remember the hadees where the prophet
saw allah
three christian scholars visit him in
masjid and navavi
and stay there to talk about islam
you know imagine muslim we and he opens
the door for the christians
to come and sit down and stay and stay
overnight
to discuss about islam that is the zeal
of dawa
that we should be having one other point
i just remembered
is just to mention that in canada right
now
there are more than 300
attacks islamophobic attacks that
happened against muslims
between 2015 to 2019 according to one of
the researchers
and 30 of those attacks were physical
attacks against muslims
there are more than 250 far-right
extremist organizations operating on
canadian soil
when we talk about lobbying these needs
to be challenged
these needs to be banned yes canadian
government has banned the proud boys
after america did it but is that the
only organization that
speaks or spews hatred not really
so we need to do two things we need to
do dawah
on one hand and on the other hand we
need to look into the legality of
the system and raise our voice for the
leaders for the politicians
to ban these outfits these terrorist
organizations
from radicalizing more
or many of the nathaniel weltman's
elsewhere
thank you so much thank you for being
with us here on the dean show my brother
i want to thank you all for tuning in
here to the dean's show and do your part
go ahead and share with your neighbor
share with your friends
share the dean show with everybody that
you know because that's what we're
dedicated to helping to clear the many
misconceptions delivering the truth
to the people and talk to your community
members to open the masjids
you know help to stop to implement some
of these things that we're talking about
and if you are a not yet muslim if
you're somebody who's tuning into the
show continue to tune in pick up a free
quran we actually we're going to have it
on our website where you can go there
todayshow.com
and we'll have it mailed to you for free
so you can see
for yourself and learn for yourself what
islam muslims are all about we'll see
you next time until then
subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification bell support us on our
patreon page we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu